e
la démocratie qui est en jeu
comme nous l'explique
Azeb Wolde-Giorghis.
♪ ♪ ♪
- C'est le sprint final avant
le 8 novembre.
Chaque parti dépêche ses ténors
pour mobiliser les troupes
et surtout inciter les gens
à voter.
"Il y va de votre sécurité
sociale, de vos soins médicaux",
dit Barack Obama.
"La frontière au sud est
grande ouverte, dit-il.
Des millions d'illégaux
envahissent notre pays", dit
Donald Trump qui n'a toujours
pas digéré sa défaite de 2020.
"La gauche radicale
endoctrine nos enfants
avec des questions de genres
et de race."
Une fois de plus, deux
Amériques s'opposent.
"C'est l'élection la plus
importante de notre histoire",
dit le président Biden.
"Notre démocratie est
littéralement en jeu."
Au Sénat, les démocrates
pourraient perdre leur siège
au Nevada. Le républicain
Adam Laxalt devance l'actuelle
sénatrice démocrate avec 46,9 %
des intentions de vote contre
45,7 pour son adversaire.
En Georgie aussi, le candidat
républicain, Herschel Walker,
est en avance d'un dixième
de point et pourrait ravir
le siège au sénateur démocrate
Raphael Warnock.
Au New Hampshire, la sénatrice
Maggie Hassan devance
de deux points seulement
le républicain Don Bolduc qui
hésite toujours à reconnaître
les élections présidentielles
de 2020.
En Pennsylvanie, Barack Obama
est venu prêter main-forte
à John Fetterman, et
Donald Trumpk à Mehmet Oz.
Les deux candidats sont
au coude-à-coude.
Au Wisconsin, le démocrate
Mandela Barnes, tente de ravir
le siège de Ron Johnson.
En Caroline du Nord et en Ohio,
les courses sont également
serrées.
Les républicains pourraient
remporter cinq sièges de plus
au Sénat, selon les sondages.
Actuellement, chaque camp
dispose de 50 élus...
- And we will fight!
-... la voix de la vice-
présidente Kamala Harris est
décisive en cas d'égalité.
En Arizona, le sénateur
démocrate Mark Kelly dépasse
de peu son rival Blake Masters
et pourrait aussi perdre
son siège.
On élit des membres du congrès,
dans ces élections de mi-mandat,
mais également des gouverneurs,
des secrétaires d'État.
"La démocratie est en péril
en Arizona", lance Barack Obama.
"Si vous avez un gouverneur,
un sénateur, un secrétaire
d'État, dit-il, qui ne
reconnaissent pas
les élections de 2020...
... la démocratie ne survivra
pas en Arizona", dit-il.
"Cette élection n'est pas
un référendum, dit-il, mais
le choix entre deux visions
fondamentalement différentes
de l'Amérique."
Azeb Wolde Giorghis,
Radio-Canada, Was